you get the call to come on the show
today to celebrate Jim Norton on his
birthday
it's Jimmy day I'm sure visions start
popping into your head to you
you've known Jimmy for many years now
actually 10% of it yeah yeah and you've
gotten to know him quite a bit in your
head what does a Jim Norton birthday
celebration kind of look like what what
visions start to pop into your brain
when you find out this is what we're
celebrating well I think it's changed I
think it's evolved like Jim when I first
saw Jim I didn't know what to make of
him I thought it was it was like angry I
like I liked him because he was angry he
was angry in south for some reason I
couldn't work out he wasn't scared of
saying anything to anyone because look
what he would do to in South and I sort
of I respected that I was and then then
I sort of realized after a while that
actually um he was like the most sort of
tolerant accepting reasonable um
comedian on the circuit it was all
attitude because it was exactly what I
what I want in a comedian you want to be
you want to be highly principled but you
can't want to be able to take a joke
it's like there's nothing makes me more
uncomfortable than someone who can't
take a joke that it's that I'm not
uncomfortable around any difference
nothing you can you couldn't bring
someone in here right no one made but
unless she said he doesn't like jokes he
takes things the wrong way out max
you've gotta talk to these [ __ ] mass
murderers for a minute right they all
chained up they were fine right if there
was one that soaked I go not get you now
yeah
I think about Jim he doesn't take
anything [ __ ] personally is is live
doing nothing nothing's nothing scary
and it's one of the few people that is
refusing to [ __ ] shut up and buy his
tongue I think if you know I think if
you did comedy comedy I'm more and more
now right
you mustn't be angry a joke if the point
of the joke is to make people laugh you
can't be angry and that's what people do
as well they they make the rules in
their heads they like these ten terrible
things you say but not that one
because that affects them and that's not
funny right and they've always got a
difference they've always got a reason
no it's worse because this that what
they mean is they don't like the
punchline
that's all they mean I liked it when you
took a piss out of the other ten things
but I didn't like it we need to put this
out of that one and they won't admit it
they think that their thing has some
sort of higher morality higher reason
not to be jealous and honestly I see it
I see it particularly with new causes
these people that go only one is to be
treated equally all we want is to be
treated the same as everyone else
but not in jokes not in jokes and and so
Jim Jim is sort of involved in my head
as well the more I realized what it was
like so my first if you'd have asked me
like you know when I first knew him I
would think that it would be the ditch
scenario now I think it would be like um
a dinner with with nice smart comedians
but and interestingly enough both
scenarios still covered income yeah
[Laughter]